i will say because i am publicly known  as an exorcist  i receive the high volume of people who  reach out to me but the majority of the  people who reach out to me have already  self-diagnosed  and any exorcist will tell you that when  somebody has  self-diagnosed ninety-nine percent of  the time it's not something demonic  ninety-nine percent of the time it's not  something that it's more like the id or  it's something else that uh absolutely  yes okay when someone self-diagnoses  meaning they think that they are  possessed by a demon  ninety-nine percent of the time it's not  accurate correct okay so they're they're  calling me and saying i'm possessed and  i need an exorcism and my response would  be  no you're not we may get to that point  yeah but we have to look at what is  actually wrong with them at that point  they're schizophrenic they're bipolar  they're on drugs their depression what's  the what's the it could be all of those  and that's why it has to be  investigated